welcome to spork blast let's blast some
sports source we got a ton of sports to
blast starting with this sports core 14
to 9 that means it's time to head over
to the wall of basketball wall of
basketballs hockey correspondent puck
talked with Ron Perry thanks Andy and
welcome to Park Talk
it's [ __ ] great to be here at a real
ice hockey game which is why you can see
my breath are you enjoying the ice
hockey game fantastic Wow
I stopped it it sure looked cold where
he was I mean it that means it sorts
that means it I will
that means it's time to check in with
senior sports flash correspondent :
O'Brien with a bunch of home run calls
thanks Andy here's a bunch of home run
calls that ball is going going dogs now
there's a bowl that won't be caught
sports it could be it might be it as a
home run is what that ball is course
holy guacamole that's a ding a ling ding
dong ideas
there's too much molasses on that
pancake all ROG boards there's too much
ketchup on that hot dog it's out of here
there's too many hot dogs on that
pancake kablooey board and that says
slab Vanille Havanese anybody's out of
the override boards they finally knock
knock who's there
ho ho ho
but what you did after you : back teeth
don't you taller than me I'm not I'm
protecting myself
let's wrap it up with the sports clip of
the week sports Quinn oh the quick
sports sports sports sports sports
Sports Wow you gotta love sports
oh boy stop it
well that's our show tune in never again
for another edition of auntie winter
sports blast
[Applause]
basketball we have a great show
that whole walls gonna cook down start a
new Netflix original movie murder
mystery Alan I don't know it's here
[Applause]